meine damen und herren wir befinden uns
hier von mcdonald's es ist nichts
werbung es nicht geblendet wird es nur
deren produkte ich willkommen hier kein
geld ich überhaupt nicht irgendwie
mcdonald's vermarkten oder keine ahnung
was allerdings habe ich vor circa einem
jahr schon mal ein video geladen wo ich
die neuesten mcdonald's produkte
getestet habe
da war ein paar sachen weil die echt
lecker fahren aber ein paar die auch
richtig laut bahn und meine damen und
deswegen haben uns gedacht wiederholen
wir das ganze heute mal und ich habe
auch hier sehen dass mcdonald's und
einen pizza menge rausgebracht hat also
einen pizza und burger doktor edgar so
war vor einiger zeit schon mal gemacht
doch bei mcdonald's teilweise nicht auf
das schmecken wird wir werden das ganze
haus setzen deswegen würde ich sagen
darf wird fahren war in mcdrive obwohl
wir schauen uns erst mal etwas überhaupt
gibt
standard wer vorne steht noch noch hallo
frau luna defizit ende vorne steht neu
lippen als tätig und hier ist der neue
pizza mac ich sagen kann einfach mal
mcdrive und schon darf ab den macd hanno
ich hätte gern auf jeden fall einmal den
neuen pizza mac
genau machen sie zwei machen sie 2 dann
hätte ich gern den lipton ice tea den 9
da bitte ich nehme den kleinen nämlich
den und dann hätte ich noch gern den mac
flury cookie dough schoko und dann was
haben sie denn noch für neue sachen
bitte
roddick
noch mal wirklich verstehen wir nicht
raus
die nehme ich doch weiter nämlich noch
einmal die big chicken viele stripes
drei witze ist der mac ritchies bacon
neu den nehme ich auch noch fünf autos
sind dann war es das
ok danke wenn wir weiterfahren
ich bin gespannt können sie das
vielleicht einmal kurz weg schmeißt
nicht nur den spiegel sorgen
aber richtig bock auf die filets 3 aber
was heißt danke zurück zur aussage
kommen freunde hier haben wir das essen
was wir uns geholt haben und dann
natürlich jedem xlord cupido und der
letzten 16 macht ja keinen sinn
beliebten risiken folgern allerdings
sind das wirklich die neuesten produkte
von mcdonald's also hier metal wrap
bacon haben wir hier am start
ich hasse halten die pest vor allem hat
er auch chili cheese drauf und keine
ahnung was werden dann haben wir damals
gerne was da drin ist und wir haben
zweifel süße soße über geil geil dass
ich jetzt ein fleck auf seiner hose hat
zwei neue pizza max aber natürlich auch
noch am start
die riechen kranken pizza ich würde
sagen ich fange jetzt mal mit dem
leichtesten an und zwar lebten afc
das heißt leicht das ist ja keine
challengers nochmals doch das normalste
froh dass ich schließlich hat die preise
ganz normaler lipton ice tea peaches
ausschluss ja normal beiseite freunde
was wir jeden haben sind die chicken
tender die kenne ich tatsächlich nur aus
amerika aber ich war jetzt auch schon
die vier fünf sechs mal in amerika und
immer wenn wir da waren wirklich
schicken tender gesetzen über gleich
weiß ich warum das in deutschland
überhaupt nicht denkbar aber ist quasi
einfach chicken nuggets mit ein bisschen
mehr kruste drin schönen diese methode
rein
ich habe ich so leben wie gesagt ich
will überhaupt nicht mcdonald's bewerben
da die methoden wie diese ganzen
produkte rausbringen es ist einfach man
kann es man kann es nicht ändern
ich will das nicht bewerten aber diese
teile schmecken eigentlich echt das okay
ich bin ich auch besser als mit geld
schicken
dabei weihte freunde als nächstes machen
wir mit was weiteres auch kein bürger
ist also nicht zum essen sondern es ist
irgendwie schon was zum essen macquarie
cookie dough leute ich bin gespannt man
könnte ja eigentlich nur von hier noch
aus dem video dieser welcher wandel
barroso cola alter
ich habe mein gott walther die richtige
ultra fdp exkurs dahin der einheit
wirklich uns besser bestellt die wasser
zu cola verwandeln in dem fall wasser
zur angesagt und haben das getriebe und
schmeckt halt wirklich orangensaft es
hat einfach so die nasen nerven
geschmacksnerven verliert dann habe
wasser eingefroren hat das jetzt drin
stehen lassen und leute ich wollte dass
ein video machen
es bringt aber gar nichts der geschmack
ist wegmann man riecht auch nichts mehr
also das hat wirklich hat überhaupt kein
ergebnis ist hinten
das gibt einem eine pizza die kommt er
am 15 10 kommt hier aus lassen leiter
bei diesem video und schreibt nach unten
in den kommentaren ob ihr bock habt das
nicht morgen euch endlich darauf bog er
da schreibt mir die kommentare ob ich
morgen ein video auf meinem kanal hier
hochladen soll wo ich euch final endlich
sagen dass das für eine pizza sein wird
also die geschmacks orte und ich habe
auch schon die kartons in den ligen 32
wenn man die kommentare wird aber heute
hier weil wir ein mcdonald's produkte
testen wollten deswegen ein cookie dough
kenne ich noch von ben & jerry's auch
überhaupt keine werbung nicht erwähne so
viele marken hier ist vielleicht ein
bisschen verwirrend dass gerade hier
wäre widerstands als service
herausgeholt aber das war
der pizza ich kenne das schon recht
transparent freunde also sieht man dass
das ist natürlich daran liegen dass es
ja schon geschmerzt aber sieht welches
einfach nur ein bisschen ekelhaft aus
ich probiere das ganze jetzt mal
es hat nichts mit google zu tun
für mich ist das ein ganz normaler
vanille schoko macquarie
ich würde ich auch sagen kommen wir zu
einem nächsten bürger und zwar dem mic
mac grip bieten durch krankheit den
feiere ich überhaupt nicht man hat schon
vom gestank ich zeige euch mal wie es
aussieht wenn ich gehe jetzt mal hier
auf den teller darauf packte also erst
mal der ist in der verpackung auch schon
geld ist hier richtig ekelhaft rinder
die ganzen soße läuft runter so sieht er
aus
dieses produkt das wirklich das ist das
allerletzte von egon ist glaube ich es
war allerdings neu deswegen wollte ich
nur aufgestellt aber das sieht doch auch
einfach das ist doch halt auch einfach
nur das außenbecken mit schmeckt
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so gut und
anders formuliert er schmeckt echt
richtigen takt hätte dass wenn die
hunger hat und ihr könnt eigentlich
alles von alles schmeckt auf einmal gut
aber bisher hat er da würde ich lieber
fahren dann hätte ich gesagt
im zuge der wissenschaftlichen zweite
ein bisschen nehmen aber das war keine
gute idee brauchen wir allerdings
meine sehr verehrten zuschauer meine
lieben damen und herren zu dem produkt
warum wahrscheinlich die meisten dieses
video hier eingeschaltet haben
mcdonald's hat es groß beworben ich bin
ein riesiger fan der freunde von einem
teil des produktes der pizza ich liebe
pizza über alles ich habe glaube ich die
meisten verschiedenen pizzen in
verschiedenen restaurants von allen
ländern weltweit gegessen überall wo ich
bin geht eigentlich die pizza auf dem
tisch deswegen bin ich gespannt was das
jetzt hier das will ich jetzt hier
erwarten wird was soll s darstellen weil
sie sich so ganz so schön sehen die
tatsächlich gar nicht mehr auf was ich
hab eine mcdonald wirklich nicht
verstehe warum nach den käse nicht ein
bisschen länger drauf guckt euch das ist
doch wir machen jetzt einfach mal auch
passiert hat sich nicht einfach gar
nichts kaufen ist einfach nur ein
bahndamm ihr fleisch hackfleisch mit mit
käse drin genau ganz normaler kind
bisher ein ganz normaler bürger einfach
tomatensoße
es ist ok sieht man es riecht strasser
pizza euer ja also es ist keine normale
ketchup sondern ist einfach tomatensoße
das ist dann tatsächlich allerdings auch
der einzige unterschied zu dem händler
dafür dass er so riesig beworben wurde
auch mit einem lied von pietro lombardi
mal bin ich ganz ehrlich kommt der im
sommer beschlossenen verpackungen guckt
euch das mal an das ist hier wirklich
etwas sondern sondern denkt ich weiß
auch nicht wie teuer der ist hier hätten
sie zumindest ein sondern vielleicht
eigentlich nicht in seine pizza
gebrandeten dingen aber gut ich gebe dem
ganzen jetzt mal ein schrei also pizza
mac von mcdonald's ist jetzt seit kurzem
draußen ich meine meine pizza kommt am
15 10 raus sehr interessant hallo ich
weiß nur dass beschreiben kann er
schmeckt wirklich so wie wenn man bei
einem kindergeburtstag ist die mutter
hat irgendwie eine pizza gemacht oder
liegen paar bürger
die nuggets und tiefe schaden jungens
kindergeburtstag irgendwie brand hat
wird von seinen burger gegessen hat noch
so hinten so reste von den bürgern dann
bei 500 pizza margherita ab so schmeckt
das allerdings schmeckt es zu 90 immer
noch nur nach burger man könnte den
ärmeln mcdonald's hamburger mit hitler
geschmack nennen aber jetzt nicht
wirklich pizza mac weil dafür hat das
viel zu wenig mit einer pizza zu tun ist
dass kinder vertritt 100 wieder 15
oder halt morgen im video sage ich euch
schon mal was es für eine
geschmacksrichtung sein wird ich bin
nicht überzeugt mcdonald's hat man
wirklich cooler machen können jetzt
starte was nun herr burger ohne so muss
man für sich selbst entscheiden wie wir
heute auch bei damen und herren ja ich
habe das ganze wie gesagt wenn man vor
einem jahr gemacht haben wir auch schon
mal mcbride maxime ich damals und haben
es auch die neuesten mcdonald's produkte
gekauft im letzten diedorf ich das ganze
euch auch gefragt wollt ihr dass ich das
ganze elend mit burger king mache oder
mit starbucks und damit kfc oder mit
pizza hut oder keine ahnung was das
unternehmen betreibt sie gehen und in
die kommentare
das machen soll nach dem letzten video
hat max und ich das irgendwie gar nicht
mehr getestet aber denke ich würde das
ganze gleich mal angehen oder wir nehmen
max nur mit oder befangen zu dritt
schreibt dort in die kommentare
[Musik]